I'm happy to be back so I studied
computer science so this was my my
department my building or not my
building
the building where I worked at and study
that so how many of you are in computer
science here that's it only what
happened or they're all they're all
programming outside so uh are the rest
of you come Stanford students here or
alums I see some friends and alums here
that's great so I'm very happy to be
here I just flew in this morning I
scheduled my flight to to be here for
Richards talk he told me there's only be
20 people so I'm really impressed by the
crowd okay so I'm here to talk about
Bitcoin and China and and my startup in
China called BTC China so just to make a
correction we actually I actually got
involved earlier this year so it's been
about eight months or so involved in BTC
China how many of you have heard of
Bitcoin I assume almost all and how many
of you have bitcoins Wow that's awesome
this is this is why this is called
Silicon Valley you guys are all into it
this is great and if those are you who
have bank accounts in China you can buy
some at my exchange afterwards so let's
do this I have two slides I've echo here
okay so I have two two decks here this
one is about about Bitcoin in China
another thing I could do is talk about
Bitcoin at a high level would you guys
want to go through some slides about
Bitcoin at a high level okay so let's do
that so I fir
prepared this deck a half a year ago so
some of the numbers may be outdated
about update you essentially let's talk
about what it's Bitcoin right so uh we
know we know it's a digital currency we
think it's a digital currency but more
importantly is it really virtual
currency or is it more like money or is
it more like an asset so what do you
guys think
how many strove hands how many guys
think it's really um really money okay
just like 12 people how many up who
thinks it's an asset or more well guess
what it turns out money an asset have a
relationship they're not exactly the
same thing but rather you know money is
really a subset of you know a kind of
asset if you will other types of assets
include stocks real estate gold and
money is one kind of asset so everybody
has money right so so it's most common
of all assets and more broadly if you
look at assets I'm gonna go over some
definitions of what makes an asset these
are the characteristics of an asset you
know it's something useful valuable
tangible it's a resource and
recognizable and then when it comes to
money it's something more specific has
to be acceptable has to be durable has
to be portable small units has to be
scarce divisible and uniformed so money
money is really a subset of asset and
then then you look at what is Bitcoin so
here's my definition of Bitcoin it's
really a digital asset so prior to
bitcoins invention five years ago the
only types of digital assets are like
email addresses or or website URLs whole
host names so bitcoin is a new digital
asset that's that behaves like money
okay it's limited scarce decentralized
peer-to-peer distributed it's pseudo
anonymous it's open source free to use
and then also has many features of
currency and money so what is money
let's let's just go through that quickly
we have examples of gold of cattle
seashells and even stones right large
stones outside in some Island and then
we have paper money all right paper
money has been around forever it feels
like but today's money is basically all
fiat
see have you guys heard of him fiat
currency the first reaction I get in
China is they think it's a car Fiat the
car
no it's Fiat is sort of derogatory term
it just means that governments declare
this money is legal tender has value by
declaration by Fiat it turns out this
wasn't the case
a century ago so today's money whether
it's the US dollar the Chinese RMB or
other other dollar currencies it's all
fiat today it's no longer backed by gold
it turns out in the early 1900 the US
dollar was backed by gold so the notion
of gold certificates $1.00 when dollar
bill was 1:21 xx of an ounce I have some
props let me see so what I have here is
one twentieth of an ounce so here's a
dollar
and this is one twenty eleven ounce of
gold this happens to be a China panda I
don't if you can the camera zoom in so
this is one twentieth of an ounce
do you know how much this is worth today
$60 that's right so one ounce is about
$1,200 so if you give me sixty or more
dollars I might give you this piece but
it used to be that one piece of this can
go you can go to bank and get one of
these guys and then if you have $20 you
get one ounce of gold now not so easy so
much so oh yeah it was on the screen
right so paper money is no longer backed
by physical assets that's good or bad
but it only started in 1971 and in
essence the fiat currency regime has
only been around for 42 years which is a
small sliver of whole of humanity so
everything before that your grandparents
your great-grandparents they used money
that was more physical intangible about
gold silver and so on
so today's bank you know the history
banks came from being depositories for
gold and silver so what's the problem
with fiat currency we know about
increasing money supply in the u.s. we
use a fancy term called QE
Accu is an acronym for a fancy word
called quantitative easing which
essentially just means printing money so
uh and this is not happening only in the
US but also in China Japan Europe
everyone's printing money and if the
whole world prints money at the same
pace guess what happens we all feel we
don't feel it because if you change
exchange US dollars for euros for
Japanese yen for Chinese RMB if they're
all increasing at the same pace then
people don't feel it so that's what's
happening in the last five years since
the financial crisis so government CPI
numbers are notoriously underreported
and the reporting true inflation so for
example I was in San Francisco today I
parked my car for 45 minutes they
charged me $12 $12 you know 15 years ago
when I was at Stanford could buy me a
lot of a lot of you know big lunch and
stuff how much does lunch cost these
days at Stanford
how much $12 Wow well anyways you know
what I mean by inflation so uh
recent example last decades country call
Zimbabwe had hyperinflation so I was why
she born in Africa in the country Ivory
Coast but thankfully not Zimbabwe but
name is name Bob we had hyperinflation
this banknote is what is it ten or
hundred trillion dollars I'll show you
I'll show you the the what I mean by
that
so they started you know with five ten
twenty dollar Zimbabwe notes and this is
very similar to u.s. dollars topping out
one hundred and they started having five
hundred one thousand five thousand ten
thousand and then you know a hundred
thousand dollars you know and then it
goes to half a million 1 million five
million at that point so I forget it
just keep going right so 25 million 50
million 100 million and and then I think
they stopped here 100 trillion really
100 trillion dollars it's a little crazy
so when you have a newspaper article
front page list you don't even count the
number zero you just know it's
ridiculous so we've got starving
billionaires on the street we have eggs
three eggs that cost 100 billion
Zimbabwe dollars and this guy I don't
know if he's moving it all depends on
what kind of bill he has right if these
are all wanting to trillion dollar notes
then I guess as he's rich but otherwise
this is a poor guy so how does the fake
real life right in China it's the same
things happening so this slides these
slides were made for China so China has
inflation has been decent you know these
were the early you know half these are
50 cent 1 RMB 2 RMB and this is the old
version of 100 RMB this is the new
version 100 RMB is about 15 US dollars
today this is their largest note and the
naturai uses how much did eggs cost so
in the 1980s you know you can get a
hundred eggs so I can get a thousand
eggs with 100 RMB and then about 10
years later you can only get one 300
eggs and today 100 RMB can get you 100
eggs so the question is what happens in
20 years can you still buy as many eggs
chicken eggs right so talk about quickly
about Bitcoin and then I'll wrap up
these slides and go to the about China
so by the way if you have questions just
raise your hand I'm speaking pretty fast
going through these so researchers have
been studying big digital currency for a
long long time I'm sure even Stanford
computer science department they've been
talking about or studying this and the
problem is double spending right if you
think about physical goods physical
goods you can give to each other and the
attributes of me giving a physical good
to someone else let's say it's this
piece of gold coin where the where is it
I lost it No
so small you know if that's if I give
this to someone then I don't longer have
it they have it by possession but as you
know in this digital age files can be
transferred and copied emails are sent
and copied there's some seats over here
in this area and the problem is how do
you prevent someone from from copying
and pasting you know digital currency or
notes so this is the topic of double
spending it's a very interesting
research problem and you know it's never
been solved until until Bitcoin came
along because dig new information can be
easily copied that's a fundamental
problem so five years ago this guy said
Toshi Nakamoto this is a pseudonym we
don't know who he is and I am NOT
Satoshi by the way people ask in my
Satoshi I'm not Satoshi if I were I
wouldn't be here
so that's what he said yeah more on that
later
so he published a paper you know it was
actually September October what does the
late 2008 five years ago exactly and
it's the first viable electronic digital
cache it's solved double spend problem
and the way they did it was using global
ledger so global ledger is where they
keep information globally distributed on
all computers keep track of how many
accounts have how many bitcoins
okay so published it by 2008 Satoshi
first viable decentralized digital
currency it has all these features it
has a cap on how many bitcoins it's
distributed peer-to-peer we talked about
that and then I'll keep going
so the softer stuff was released almost
five years ago in January 2009 so next
month will be the first with a five year
anniversary of Bitcoin so at that time
there were no bitcoins in existence and
then it has an algorithm to generate
these bitcoins and it's given away for
free to people who participate in the
mining process so right now as of today
there's little over 12 million it's open
source free to use very secure uses high
grade encryption but same public private
key technologies that we're familiar
with on the internet ok very transparent
all transactions are public all Ledger's
are public so everybody can see what's
going on and the pseudo anonymous the
the difference is that account numbers
are not linked to real people's names so
you have Bitcoin accounts that have
bitcoins in them you don't know who has
it but at least what's in there how I
got there who sent it and how it's got
sending how much is all visible so
here's a symbol the B with the with the
line through it the interesting thing is
you know where they borrowed this from
you know what currency they borrowed
this symbol from Thailand so they
borrowed this symbol from Thailand you
know the US dollar has the S with the
line through it the euro has the e with
the line through it you know and so on
so forth
so so the side story is that of all the
countries in the world the only one
that's come out to criticize Bitcoin is
Thailand
it's true story the central bankers say
old Bitcoin is bad bad bad so I wonder
if it's to do with the symbol anyway so
circulations capped at 21 million I'll
explain that a little bit yes please
five years old on per circulation is
half of the total yes so so it's growing
at 150 per hour so as we speak over the
course of the next hour there will be
150 new bitcoins created out of thin air
and then that that's a rate of 2,600 a
day and then and then it takes 130 years
to get to 21 million and then you ask
wouldn't it take much sooner it wouldn't
take you know wouldn't be much faster
than 130 years the reason is that
actually the speed at which the bitcoins
come out actually slow down over time
every four years it slows down by half
so you used to be four years ago it used
to be 50 bitcoins per 10 minutes 300 per
hour 7200 per day so now it's half of
that in four years will be half of this
in four years after that will be another
half of that and so on until very very
small so that that's how it reaches 21
million okay get a question over there
okay so how does become work so regular
bank accounts you all have bank accounts
right so the US does not have an under
banking problem but do you spend all
your money do you spend your whole
paycheck every month that I've heard
that Americans spend all their paycheck
so that's how you know so that's why
when I see you know zero for your bank
account balance I don't know if it's a
start banking account balance or whether
that's your current bank balance but
anyway so let this sorry this is in RMB
un but the idea see you when you deposit
money to your bank you put in the cash
they don't track the serial numbers of a
cash did you say oh you know what keep
track of it 1000 you know dollars or
whatever and then when you withdraw
there just do 2 minus 300 and you're
left with 700 right so that's called the
ledger system okay
for those of you accountants
but these Ledger's are kept private Lee
by the bank and then only known by the
bank okay but bitcoin is stored in a
public ledger what happens is this
information is stored repeatedly copied
everywhere around the internet for the
whole world so many copies that's why
it's called distributed and same thing
we got bank account numbers we got
Bitcoin account numbers and then in each
bake bacon account there's the number of
bitcoins okay so the in this case
bitcoin accounts are not just numbers
but letters so this would be an example
of a Bitcoin account this long string of
number numbers and letters uppercase
lowercase and so on and the same thing
you start with the balance zero and they
put some bitcoins in there you take some
bitcoins out you know and you keep track
of how much you have so that's why in
digital world bitcoins don't exist by
themselves and like real money bitcoin
only exists as a number in an account as
a ledger does that make sense so when we
ask how many Bitcoin do you have you
don't actually have the bitcoins what
you do is you have access to account
numbers to have Bitcoin in them it's a
small distinction if you care please so
in the world there's only three days to
get bitcoins today the first waste is
the mining process I think well I'll
come back to that it's the same question
come back today bitcoin is just a public
okay so we'll just yeah and then and
then use the public part of the key so
the bitcoins in a Bitcoin account are
locked by a password if you will along a
very long password and that's like the
private key to the Bitcoin address
account okay so a wallet is a
terminology you know these computer
science people came up with these terms
I didn't come up with these so a wallet
is like a collection of Bitcoin accounts
that you put in your computer okay so
you have to keep that secret
anyways compared to fiat currency I
remember your questions and we'll come
back to that compare fiat currency
Bitcoin has a limit hard limit of 21
million however it has many more decimal
places so can you think of a currency
that has two decimal places US dollar
he's encouraging that has zero
Japanese Japanese yen that's right okay
think of something that has eight
decimal places and what I'll ripple yeah
okay so yeah crypto same same class so
it's not controlled by government okay
that's very important so not controlled
by government it is issued by the people
running the program and it's worldwide
it crosses all cultures all language all
countries all barriers so it runs on the
Internet
anonymous transactions very low
transaction fee and also the notion of
no charge back the notion of finality so
how many of you have businesses where
you accept credit cards any business
owners here the notion or we have for
you okay so notion if you if you if your
business a restaurant you take credit
cards if your customer pays by credit
card you're supposed to get that $40 for
their lunch but in reality you'll find
out a month later whether you get the
money sometimes the bank calls you say
oh that was fraud sorry we're not gonna
pay you so there's a risk of taking
credit cards that's why they charge such
high fees and so on so with Bitcoin once
you accept the Bitcoin once you have
proof you got it there's it's it's it's
it's sure thing there's no a risk of not
getting it and there's no such thing as
a fake Bitcoin because everything can be
authenticated so from that perspective
merchants really like accepting bitcoins
open source peer-to-peer so conclusion
quickly three things oK we've got the
asset value aspect so the the key notion
here is Bitcoin because of its limited
supply and it's that and it's and its
functions and properties like no
counterparty risk it makes a really a
valuable asset the second thing is it's
very has high integrity because of the
transparent nature decentralized global
network the notion of it's open source
and open for inspection so everybody can
go inspect the security aspect of it and
lastly it's very secure and safe because
of the high grade encryption so Bitcoin
itself is very secure but you still once
you have bitcoins you have to keep track
of your of your private keys you don't
want to lose it it's like if I give you
like five kilograms of gold you don't
want to just leave it on your living
room
counter right you want to lock it away
in a safe so it turns out Bitcoin is
very much like gold it's an electronic
version of gold with many properties and
now let me run over some prices and I'll
talk about the mining aspect so how many
of you heard about bitcoins in 2011 wow
I'm impressed
did you guys buy it back then see if you
bought it you wouldn't be here right
you'd be like vacationing somewhere so I
did not buy any bitcoins either so too
bad but but but back in 2011 there was a
bubble right people call the big bump
Bitcoin bubble of 2011 so went from a
few dollars you know under one or two
dollars for those who remember those are
good old days and then when all the way
up to $30 and it came crashing down and
we're like Oh see this is virtual
currency just for kids forget about it
so end up being $10 and that's when my
brother introduced me to Bitcoin
I started mining it I'll tell you about
that later
so peaked over $30 and then this year I
I got involved and that's what no that's
not because of me but well I got
involved around here started buying and
I told the rest of the world please buy
please buy and then no no that's a joke
also people think it's a Ponzi scheme
but it's not so so the price did indeed
keep going up this is a US dollar charge
so by April this year how many of you
bought bitcoins this year around March
April so there was a Cyprus event you
know where the government says oh you
banks with you money let me just take a
big chunk out of it and people got all
worried about putting money in banks so
uh that's what triggered the Bitcoin
stuff and in April is when the
mainstream media started covering it so
it peaked out at about $265 on a big
Bitcoin exchange and then guess what
happened so it popped and it came back
down to about $100 so went up like
near-vertical comes back down but you'll
notice this time by going from twenty
thirty dollars to two sixteen coming
back down this is this looks like a
bubble right looks like the dot-com
bubble crash of the 1999 or 2000 but
what happens is the previous bubble into
eleven looks like a small speed bump in
comparison I mean it was a bubble too
but it's like it's much small it's like
almost like fractal behavior yeah study
fractal fractals in computer science
anyways
so uh this is interesting so I was like
hey this is this might keep happening
just sure enough later this year you
know it went up again and this time it's
the Chinese people buying it and I was
involved I'm guilty so I'll tell you
about that in a little bit so so prices
hovered around $100 this summertime the
summer doldrums and it went up and then
by late September we actually I'll tell
you about a company did but but but the
price it kept going up so now what do
you think's gonna happen after your
October you guys are the price to pick
one today so so I'll show you the next
slide this is what this word gets killer
so it turns out in the last two months
it went from two hundred US dollars to
$1,100 okay crazy growth here and it
makes the April bubble look like a speed
bump and makes the March sorry the 2011
looks like ants I mean this this was the
same curve you saw in like four slides
ago that was very steep and you know so
this is kind of crazy huh so you saw
this bubble and it's not quite a bubble
after all when you see this big guy and
the question is what's gonna happen in
the next two years five years will it
come crashing down and and that's it or
will there be bigger and bigger price
increases that make this guy look like
this guy interesting question so I know
what I think but I don't want to bias
your thinking okay so some common
misunderstandings so Bitcoin does not
replace government fiat currency so the
proposal is not to say the whole world
we get rid and burn all the dollars burn
all the euros and get rid of it that's
not the point okay so anyone who says
Bitcoin will never replace fiat currency
I'm like you're right they won't and
then secondly goods and services don't
need to be priced in Bitcoin so even
when I went parking or you have lunch
somewhere you don't have to
the pricing doesn't have to show Bitcoin
price but but what we're saying is in
theory you could pay for it using
bitcoins right and then lastly the
security aspect people say bitcoin is
not safe and so on but the reality is
Bitcoin itself is very safe it's just
that you don't want you wanna you want
to safely store it yourself it's like
gold itself is very has strong integrity
it's not gonna melt or disappear or
vaporize so gold is very solid and
stable just like Bitcoin bitcoin is very
solid and stable just make sure you take
great care of it so it's the default so
let's say I put a junket let's say I put
this right here right you know I put it
right here and I walk out into the
bathroom you guys talk and then I come
back half an hour later it's gone so
whose fault is that is it me or is it
the gold it's me same thing right if I
have Bitcoin I have become right here by
the way this is now worth a thousand
dollars huh okay you can't have it if
you take it then you're stealing it but
but but let's say I have this Bitcoin
here I leave it here and then I can't
find it late as my fault the fault is
not because of the Bitcoin okay so so
one more thing this will people ask
people worried about Bitcoin where there
has value what can you buy with it so
the analogy is uh so the Rio this is a
misunderstanding I what I want to get
across is Bitcoin has value not because
of what you can buy from it it's the
other way around once Bitcoin has value
you will be able to buy things with
Bitcoin okay so so this is what I'm
saying yeah so you will be buy things
with Bitcoin once Bitcoin has inherent
value and a market value
okay so here's the here's a chart for
you for those of you who didn't follow
what I was saying has unique properties
we went over that it's scarce and
limited no misspellings okay good I
spelled it wrong last time and has
market valley and market price so think
about that has features that make it
valuable net then it has value with
value comes the market price right for
example what is this a bottle of Safeway
water is this does it have unique
features that make it valuable
yes does it have market value yes
does it have market price does it
it hasn't has a sale price but doesn't
have a bid price
well someone offer me money to take it
off my hand is it yes no yeah yes so so
has market price and then are people
willing to accept it so once it has
market price then people willing to
accept it because then thing can say
okay I can sell it I could trade it
right if you can think of this gold
right for most of you out here except if
you work unless you're working in the in
the chip industry where you can actually
turn the gold into internships most of
you have no use for gold am i right
what you do with it is you might sell it
to someone else who pay you cash for it
so once it has value yes question gold
is beautiful so is water this is like
transparent you know water keeps you
alive though to each her own to each his
own okay so we're this gold water or
Bitcoin some people will find gold more
valuable more attractive than others and
same with Bitcoin some people are more
building a bigger belief in a Bitcoin
some people be smaller believes or
believers of Bitcoin but the point is
once enough people think it has value it
would have a market price today Bitcoin
already has a market price this thing
here you know it's made of copper or tin
whatever it but has a password on the
back to the account number and this is
worth over a thousand US dollars today a
little crazy so people once it has
market value people won't accept it if I
go to Safeway today and I say hey I tell
the cashier I want 10 cases of this
water and I'm gonna give you this and if
he's smart he would say yeah I'll take
that you know so when they start
accepting it then people can what buy
things with it and when more people can
buy things with Bitcoin what happens the
cycle goes back and there's more value
so that's the that's the value chain for
Bitcoin ok future Bitcoin cannot be
stopped because unless you turn off the
internet it's peer-to-peer it's it's
it's kind of BitTorrent it crosses all
firewalls and stuff like that so it
cannot be stopped
by the government or by a country cannot
be confiscated because it's just numbers
you can store in your head you can't
confiscate it it turns out you know
which cut you know there's a country
that's actually confiscated gold from
from its people have you heard of that
yeah United States that's right this
very country at one point confiscated
all gold made gold illegal so even if
they make Bitcoin illegal they won't be
able confiscated okay and lastly we're
saying that Bitcoin exchanges will be
more and more regulated by government so
uh some of us know it better than others
we're facing the same problem we'll chat
afterwards especially today yeah what a
crazy day well I'll share with you that
in a little bit of question why can US
bank accounts be linked to most
exchanges and then why can't we baster
but no one else that's not a question I
can address in this talk I'll talk to
you afterwards about that thank you
bitcoins from from some some person who
was operating in Italy an illegal
business so if you if you are - not you
but if someone were to operate a legal
business selling marijuana and cocaine
and then the f who would be the DEA
comes in and bust them and takes all
their money and all their drugs you know
so it would be it'd be similar to that
but the problem is not with the money
the problem is not with the cash the
problem is with the operate of the
business they were doing something
illegal right so this is the year of
Bitcoin more users more startup success
Laura okay
so quickly let me go through mining okay
so it turns out it turns out that how a
Bitcoin is created so so let me before I
do that it turns out you can only get
bitcoins one of three ways I want you
guys to anyone sleeping here know so so
yes which way then you get bitcoins
money there we go
was a bit rounded it's awesome you sell
something barter give me something
I'll give you actually well I what kind
of community okay
so buying mining or or barter trading it
okay that's the only three ways you can
do it so for Bitcoin exchanges when we
specialize in is allowing people to buy
and sell bitcoins okay and then the
other companies that allow people to do
mining but what I'm going to talk about
now is the mining park quickly and they
want to go to the slide about China
okay so the process of obtaining
bitcoins is called mining you obtain it
for free so let me let me let me
backtrack a little bit
so the guy who designed it created it
decided to send a limited by 21 million
we remember that we he said a hard lemon
21 million now how do you think came up
with that was that I just random number
or was that through consensus so it
doesn't matter how you came up with it
what's important is the limit is set
okay so it's kind of like if there's a
skyscraper before you build it the
architect decides how many floors how
high alcohol it should be so that
decisions been made in the architecture
design of the skyscraper and then you
start building it one floor by one four
by one floor okay so so my point is that
this the the height of the building was
set before the building was built same
thing that the number of bitcoins was
set before bitcoins was sent out okay so
if you're the inventor of Bitcoin you
decide on 21 million who should get the
21 million bitcoins how many choices are
there give me some examples raise some
hands okay okay that's one way give it
evenly to all the citizens of the world
what's that way large a lot of you give
it out whoever wants to come to the
lottery that's the second way what's the
third way answer my question who should
get the 21 million bitcoins so I'll tell
you if it were me I could say I'll give
it all to me first right
so basically I take all the bitcoins and
then I'll see who are my good friends
and bad friends and I'll give to some
but if I did that my coin probably
wouldn't be successful so he didn't do
that
so what he decided to do is this he
decides to give all the coins away for
free to the whole world however there's
a there's a mechanical process basically
there's logistics how do you decide
who's alive who's not another way to do
is give it to the government right give
it to the United States government or
give it to the the People's Republic of
China so that wouldn't work either right
so he decided to give it away for free
to everyone and he decided to do it at
us at a time swear half the coins are
given away in the first four years and
then the next four years half of that
are given away has the remaining ones
you give away and then every four years
fewer and fewer and fewer bitcoins you
giving away buts given to it for free
and the way you get it for free is you
bring a computer you run the program you
do one calculation for every one
calculation you get a lottery ticket
just a free lottery for every 125
bitcoins are given away every ten
minutes that's today it turns out four
years ago they gave out 50 bitcoins
every ten minutes okay you got that so
it's a free lottery it really is free so
if you guys heard about Bitcoin five
years ago four years ago you could have
run this program you can get you just
press lottery ticket
I have larger ticket I'll do a live
example I'm supposing that kimoto I put
this program out here for the first
lottery I raise my hand all right no
other okay I win I got my first 50
that's what happened he got his first 50
second ten minutes okay oh oh all right
okay okay okay got it so it's one of us
you know you get one fifty chance okay
the third time ie more people okay the
fourth time the fifth time the sixth
time yama raise two hands what the heck
you guys to any of you out there the
sixth time what happens so ever is
raising two hands and then what's
happening is if you're more computers
you press a button twice do you have
more computers come on so the more
computer brain to raise hands for you
the more chance of York you have at
winning the lottery does that make sense
and this is what the what the game is
about the mining game so today you hear
about people going buying specialized
computers and plugging them in
just to you know play this okay I'm
serious I'm really serious about this is
a big business should play the lottery
run the program guessing number this is
where the where the crypto hash stuff
comes in and you get the prize okay so
the difficulty turns out if they're more
people playing the game what happens
your chance of winning goes down right
yes no yes yes
honestly no yes okay so what what they
did was they ran programs on their CPUs
and then to turn the GPUs these are the
graphics chips and then it made special
chips to do it they're called a six so
it's gotten harder and harder and people
join in to polls so what happens is if
I'm raising five hands and I can't win
what happens I tell my whole Stanford
computer science department hey let's
all do this together
you know let's join us one team will
race hands together and we and we try to
win the lottery and if we do win it will
split evenly amongst ourselves and
that's called the mining pool so
everyone's doing that now so I got into
this 2011 my brother introduced me to it
my first mining rig tada
I spent $1,000 on that you know to power
supplies for graphics cards
so if you know how fast raise hand
erased hands 220 million times a second
so every second okay no joke no joke
so after course of ten minutes the price
comes out did I win
nope they're way too many people raising
hands out there so I didn't win but
anyways I joined these mining pools so I
got fractions of a Bitcoin so over three
months I earned about 20 bitcoins at the
time was doing the dollars I like this
is not profitable turn it off so I
turned it off what a waste
so today this year I got excited again
my brother called me say Bobby there's
this new thing called ASIC chip these
are chip designed for Bitcoin mining
made in China and now it's 80 times 85
times faster so I got one of these boxes
under my desk
it cost me $1500 and there's like a five
month waiting list and anyways at one
point I was earning two bitcoins a day
to bitcoins that so you think wait I
thought the prize was 25 bitcoins per
ticket right then how do I get something
less than that so it's the mining pool
by doing the mining pool we win once
every so often and then we would divvy
it up so so I got my share which was two
bitcoins a day so that was a pink that
was my absolute peak I got two big coins
a day at the time was $100 so was that
okay so so this was 72 Giga hash 72
billion times a second the other guy was
220 million times a second so this thing
is this race is going fashion it's like
the arms race like super fast okay so
anyways so this answer the question so
at the time we were making yeah it
difficulty will rise okay so that's it
Bitcoin is uh you know buy some bitcoins
and so let me take some questions that I
gloat about one about China
we have half an hour left yeah okay good
yes difficult is rising why not just
abandoned bitcoins that go to light
coins or the next new coin it sees good
you could is prisoner choice Bitcoin
right now is still the most most desired
of all cryptocurrencies it's because
it's original and it turns out of the
ones you mentioned these guys are all
there there's a whole bunch there's
about 50 or 60 cryptocurrencies you
could you could do your own are you a
computer science student no you have a
computer connection yes you can go
download a Bitcoin source code change
the name what's your name
wait wait oh wait coin some I should
send an email to everyone else to come
use it and maybe we'll use it but but
the thing but there are millions of
people using Bitcoin today so the
question is will they use yours or will
they use Bitcoin so that's the question
I question the back valuation wise if
you want to start a new style which cost
you with you which culture which counts
which country China nationalize well my
wife's regulation regulation wise yeah
not Thailand not the US I don't know
it's that's a long question I'll talk
about that at the end yeah
any other questions yeah oh there what
do you think have you seen a killer app
for Bitcoin in China or what we're still
very early killer apps you know people
think it changes was a killer business
it is it isn't there's more to come
there's many many more to come so if
you're interested you State stay stay in
tune with the market there's a lot more
killer apps coming yeah questions
because my brother invented it no really
my brother Charles Lee he created like
coin so he did what Wayne was gonna do
you plan out there pull the source code
change to light coin change a few things
and published it and for those of you
know you know it's now pretty popular
the second most popular cryptocurrency
yeah so he's the guy who got me into
Bitcoin that he didn't like you didn't
even tell me about it way too much like
he was like doing this himself and even
tell me about okay question somehow the
fractional importance
function of bitcoins each Bitcoin has
eight decimal places so you could send
0.5 0.5 v 0.005 to anyone you want what
do you get any time one price comes
that's 25 bitcoins and the rumor gets it
can then split up 280 pieces they want
ok question the back at the Bitcoin
exchange I'll deal with our money okay I
know that the next slide okay so one
more question in our chain slides go
ahead sir in the back do you have any
idea of how many people hold that point
no idea we can know what he tell you how
many accounts they are do we know if
there's any experts here how many cows
there are how many producers I'm
watching it's in the in the middle and
the hundreds of millions
but we don't know how many people behind
that yeah okay so so here's we spend
maybe another 15 minutes talk about
Bitcoin in China and then and then we'll
take questions and answers and I'm here
until you know whenever you guys are
want to ask more questions okay so I'm a
co-founder of BTC China we started out
being a local regional operator we still
are a local region operator in China but
but we our traffic has gone up a lot so
so now we're getting some worldwide
attention so quick history the site was
launched by my two co-founders in June
of 2011 and then and then I joined this
year as CEO and co-founder in April and
at that time we became the world's
number five largest Bitcoin company by
July we established a company we went
out fundraising for VC money we set up
office headquarters office in Shanghai
and by then we've climbed the world
number three position and in September
we eliminated all trading commissions so
that was industry first to spur the
pickle market in China and then by by
early November we've risen to world
number one position in Bitcoin volume
trading so that's and later in September
as I laid in November two weeks ago we
announced our Series A funding by
Lightspeed Venture Partners that's our
VC money and today we've so we
essentially we expanded really fast from
25 employees and our trading volume has
gone up so give you some perspective so
the line is the price and the bars or
the volume okay so we saw a pretty
stable price and volume all summer long
right you may remind these crazy charts
I showed you that was because I
compressed the time but when you spread
it out from June to September it was
pretty much pretty flat the price okay
the volume was pretty flat and then when
we announced that the low Commission the
no Commission or volume took off okay
that's a bar and then what happened the
price took off as well so this is weird
if you think about economics what thing
gets more expensive as more people buy
it it's usually the way around usually
when price comes down volume goes up
right if a car you know if they reduce
the price for for a car for model the
car what happened is spur
sales sales go up right but this is sort
of the opposite what you're seeing here
is the volumes go up and the price goes
up something very limited in quantity
something that has true limitations in
quantity that's what you see right we
see the volume go up first and then this
price go up okay so on the just by
coincidence on the day we announce our
VC funding pick one price doubled so I
remember we were preparing the press
release on Saturday Sunday we're the
release of Monday morning at the time
over the weekend it was two thousand
five million RMB and by the time it hit
the press in the morning it was 3,000
grand and went for four thousand and
went to five thousand by evening time we
couldn't sleep my wife and I were there
in the bed we couldn't sleep was a six
thousand and the next morning was seven
thousand so that one day November 18th
was a key day it went up like double the
price and that's probably when you guys
all heard about it question yes you
obviously know it took months at some
point yeah okay now they are obviously
non-driving
well set the interest at in terms of
feast and the professor on to use you
say yeah we'll see I can't I can't
comment on what we will do in the future
but the example point out is in the past
if Google hotmail and Twitter all
charged per search per email sent or per
Twitter sent the internet will not be
where it is today right not just that
but to spur the whole industry to spur
the whole industry and I think we're we
I think we've made a positive impact
there right if think about webs
if web search was paid if hotmail yahoo
mail Gmail counts were paid for every
email you sent had to be paid I don't
think the internet would be where it is
today if every Facebook like if every
Facebook message if every Instagram
thing was paid for you had to pay for it
I don't think the internet would be
where it is today
so I was up close and personal in front
with the internet you know 20 years ago
out here in Silicon Valley
our thinking was that's why I went to
raise the VC money we wanna we want the
long haul we want we don't want the
short term profit we want the long term
industry success for Bitcoin so we focus
on the China market so China arm be
strictly only trying to pick China yeah
okay so uh more questions yes one more
article this week yeah you want to sell
me some bitcoins I'll take it so we did
a user survey customer survey who are
users so quickly
we had about 45,000 responses 15 days we
give an iPad I say this because to be
all fair and honest right because if you
think about servers are never accurate
you know so in our case we told people
take the survey in the surprise so
sometimes that skews the the audience
but but it is what it is so here are the
results
ninety ninety percent mail so
predominantly we think are usually
predominantly male no it's true it's
true so where are all these female
Bitcoin users I don't know so and then
you know young forty thirty age you know
predominantly and then this is very
interesting education level very high
level of education so the national
average in China is 27 percent holding a
university degree but in our user study
over 90 percent have had university
bachelor master's or even PhD degrees so
it's very very high it's very
well-educated crowd people who
understand Bitcoin and why are they
buying it so the predominantly is for us
for investment either long term or short
term I put them in the same bucket it's
basically two sides the same coin and
then very few people buying Bitcoin
today in China for the purpose of
spending it so this is the behavior in
the Western world we're seeing this in
the US people buying people use pecans
you buy things pay for things in China
this hasn't caught up yet
China still in the early stages people
primarily buying it for the appreciation
value potential okay and then investment
level experience this is uh so it turns
out the more experienced you are the
more you buy it for long-term holding
the least experience you are investing
sort of maybe by age or whatever you
just use in experience you're just
speculating you're just buying and
selling button flipping it okay this is
what we're seeing inside this I guess
this is intuitive here's an interesting
slide so six months ago or eight months
ago
predominantly Bitcoin was traded in US
dollars though of all the world's
exchanges most bitcoins are traded in US
dollars and what we saw happen in the
course of six months in China is that by
november there are more bitcoins traded
using RMB than in the US dollar so this
is a pretty crazy so and then let's talk
about why the adoption in China why the
fast adoption in China these are the
four reasons I cite some of these are
more publicly known China is a nation of
savers so high savings rate also is very
strong in math and science a lot of
Chinese people like are good at math and
science they study math and science
engineering because mining is very very
popular in China all the electronics all
the chips all the supply chain is all in
China from mining and then also the
people in China are just eager to
participate in anything new so there's
that wow factor the effector okay so a
nation is saver so this is about the
country you know you know big GDP and
people say for the rainy day you know
poor social help social care system
welfare system underdeveloped financial
sector for all these reasons people tend
to want to save okay under valid
currency and so on essentially Bitcoin
presents as a great opportunity to store
value and to preserve spending power
purchasing power okay I know you guys
think it's crazy you spend all your
paycheck every month right mostly but
what's the joke you guys Americans spend
you're more than the paycheck yeah and
how do you get the financing credit card
and China
student debt you take a you take another
home loan home equity loan I don't know
you mortgage your children you know so
second thing is a nation of engineers
right so China in China engineering
doesn't have that stigma attached to
when you study engineering in the u.s.
you know you know there's the term like
geeks
you know like nerds you know so I mean I
was computer science I was an
engineering student so I know I know
it's not what a Sanford it's okay
Stanford you know there's the there's
the techies and the fuzzies right but
most people a lot of people out in other
universities get Liberal Arts degrees so
it turns out political elite and
business leaders are much more likely to
have engineering background in China
this is just a reflection of society in
China right so this is true at the
national level the government level
national state city level and all that
so here's the next slide so it turns out
if you look at the background of our of
the presidents of China that leaders the
Premier's all three of these guys you
guys know these people
ya know yes this is a guy in charge now
chairman Xi Jingping
and this is uh his predecessor who Intel
and the one before is a chance' Ming so
they all have engineering degrees
electrical engineering hydraulic
engineering Chemical Engineering
so imagine finding that at the White
House or the Senate or the house right
so not very popular in the US you know
what they are in the u.s. they're all
lawyers okay and that's why you have
u.s. regulation on Bitcoin by lawyers so
that's a question that's the answer okay
so why do you purchase Bitcoin so that
most so most of the other reasons is
because they think it's a novelty it's
like you know it's something new you
know we're bored we just want to try
something new so they're buying bitcoins
the it factor okay so government
regulation so here's a caveat the next
few slides is a caveat so turns out on
my flight over here
they said Bobby left the country so
let's put regulation in now no but it's
sort of a joke but that's what happened
I got on the plane and then when I
landed there's a big news and China
there about there's some regulation
stuff going on so I cannot comment on
that yet because I haven't read the
paper I cannot
comment on that I'd be saying things
wrong so everything you see here is
based on my thoughts you know from from
last weekend before okay so apologize
for that and please don't quote me in
the press for anything I'm about to say
about Chinese regulation so they don't
like they obviously well I shouldn't
even say that okay my point is I'm C C
I'm not I'm not these guys right so
they're in power I'm just following what
they say so
so this optimism for Bitcoin in China so
it turns out the Vice Minister of the
Central Bank made some positive comments
there's widespread coverage by CCTV the
state television channel and so this is
this guy Egon this he's a he's very
powerful guy he's the vice minister of
the People's Bank of China which is a
central bank he's also runs the state
administration of foreign exchange
so he made he's the most knowledgeable
and the most suitable person in the
whole government to be commenting on and
to be regulating Bitcoin so if Bitcoin
ever gets regulated in China then they
will go to him for his advice and you
know he'd be most likely the person to
lead the effort in fact I think that's
what's happened in the last 24 hours so
so in November he commented three things
basically said the the government cannot
recognize bitcoins legal status as the
currency in the near term which which is
which is okay which is to be expected
right and then secondly is however he
said in China people should have the
basic right to buy and sell bitcoins so
essentially it protects our business
which what we do is we allow me to buy
and sell Bitcoin so our business is now
considered no longer in the blacklist
it's now in the white list of things
that are approved right and with caveats
with conditions and rules and stuff like
that and then bitcoins very interesting
you know so he will keep following it so
a lot of coverage in the state media
television and so the future is bright I
think for Bitcoin in China and yeah so a
lot of Bitcoin trading in China so
that's my that's that completes my
prepared remarks I'm happy to take more
questions we have about 15 minutes left
so it looks about right Richard one
comment
actually I asked you about the business
model for the exchange yes yes okay how
do you make your money yeah so let's
cover that so it turns out when we were
targeting target 0.3% one way so if you
buy bitcoins we charge the 0.3% you sell
we charge you 2.3 percent Montauk's
who is Emperor's and a Samoan
Mongkok charge 0.6% so they're raking it
in they're making so much money and
we're making half as much money but
which was a lot so we're making a lot of
money back then that's how we got VC
funding we we you know we we told the
VCS hey we're making a lot of money give
me more money so so that happened and so
today we've actually eliminated trading
commission but we we were investing for
the long-term growth of the ecosystem we
want more Bitcoin users out there want
the infrastructure to be more developed
that's why we're doing this so we might
be burning cash in the near term but
turns out what happened was the the we
still charge a little bit when you
withdraw money from the bank his banking
system so there's some withdrawal fees
that we do still charge in order to
change turns out because the volumes
have got a 100 times even based on those
tiddly those really small withdrawal
fees that's like a lot of money so
November was I actually quite profitable
I said wow we didn't realize that so
member was gonna is a really profitable
month December and so on
so we're looking we're looking pretty
good in terms of our financial model and
stuff like that okay
yeah for sure okay question yes any
issues with false Pau oh yeah we do we
do people coming in pretend to be
someone else they want their money and
stuff like that yeah all kinds all kinds
is the finality problem if you need a
bank transfer from A to B and then later
on they determined to be fraud banks can
reverse it right Bank the two banks you
know Wells Fargo Bank America they can
say oh that was fraud we would reverse
it same with credit card right if you
get charged for something there's fraud
to reverse it turns out Bitcoin you
can't once Bitcoin leaves account a and
go to account B it's at the sole
discretion of
beholder - to do what they want to do
with with a Bitcoin so you cannot
reverse the Bitcoin so that's both good
and bad in some scenarios you want that
in other cases in fraud activities it's
too bad so when you have Bitcoin
websites that get hacked and the Bitcoin
gets stolen then it's gone it's it's out
the door the horses have left the you
know the barn yes absolutely start start
up and you'll get funding if you can do
that absolutely yes it's unlimited
it's the sky's the limit I have more
ideas than I can implement so I
encourage all of you to start making
companies seriously all right this is
the new frontier like some of the ones
you start some might compete with me but
it's okay right it's like imagine if the
internet only had one Yahoo and that was
the whole thing that was the only
company for the internet now they'll be
bad we the internet would not be where
it is today
so even I worked for Yahoo it was good
to have all these competing companies in
the ecosystem so so there's many ideas
you know not because then it'll give you
an impression that I'm focused on some
areas and not others so I rather not but
you can find them online there's tons of
ideas I'll try with you offline you know
about that yes question have you thought
about using like a marking marking to
make money I predict in the bottom
movement the chain propriety trading
right so we use customers money to trade
yeah yeah that's a that's a business
model right you could do that but we as
an exchange we're not doing that but I
know people who are doing this arbitrage
businesses market making there's you
know this algorithm trading and all that
question there do you see the long-term
viability
orab you see that is just a window of
time that you have our money from the
students are these long-term it's like
the Internet they talked about internet
bubble but reality is internet you
should just blown up and it will only
keep going up so yeah question here
could you foresee happening that would
reverse the UN stance sorry what did you
see happen that would reverse the amang
stance the u.s. sent you a the Yuki Gong
are you going his gaze on what on it
being okay and it being kosher for now
and you'd be on the wait list I cannot
comment on that so it turns out in the
last twelve hours that the government
issued some rulings or some some
communique on Bitcoin I haven't read
that fully yet so I don't want to
comment on on that information
yeah I'd be speaking out of turn let me
let me go read study that and then
gather my thoughts and see the reaction
and then we'll comment on it yes please
even if you can't come in on the
regulations it sounds like the
regulations coming out was a bit of a
surprise for you or did you expect
something to be coming out we're
actually we're actually poor regulation
this may come as a surprise to some of
you
we operate in China market we want the
government to regulate the Bitcoin
exchange business and the reason is
we're the leader so we want to you know
to make this a more formal business to
me to have more rules in place or that
we do things legitimately would protect
the customers interests we protect their
funds otherwise Bitcoin actions come up
and go they steal customers money they
go out of business they get hacked so a
lot of lot of problems if it's not
regulated yeah question other than
making transfers free right yes you guys
do anything offline did you guys do
anything else today not yet we haven't
done anything offline yet yes
question over here yes can you explain
the difference between the exchanges in
the exchange became the bid-ask oh oh
you mean why change around have
different pricing oh yeah I can talk
about that so it turns out they're the
hundreds of exchanges or maybe not
hundred but ends of the chains around
the world and they all have different
prices some are higher some are lower
and the reason is that's natural market
right the water here in Safeway Mountain
View or Palo Alto is at one price if you
go to Los Angeles different parties go
to Boston you're
different price the reality is if it's
cheaper here in theory you could buy it
the water here and ship it to New York
City and sell it there for higher price
but you incur there's a reason why it's
higher there it is but remember the
audience is different right the source
of the water is different right people
who selling is different the people
buying is different that would be called
the or arbitrage business yeah question
like ten years down the road can you
scratch some ways bitcoins really
changed the world
ah Wow
it's it's the classic stuff you could
its oh let me put it this way Bitcoin
has a potential to be the first truly
global unit of measurement for value
think about this and in the US you guys
are like not you but I'm also American
but but we're we're like insulated well
what what what measuring system do we
use the American system right where we
talk about feet and inches where we talk
about towns and what's the other thing
we use in China the rest of world they
all use a metric system right so the
metric system consists of temperature in
Celsius consists of length in meters
consists of weight in kilograms consists
of what else but the point is the whole
world uses the same system of
measurement okay where is the US
different so so if you look at
currencies today the world has no 100
different currencies so the only pseudo
currency that's Globo is the US dollar
so you know the US dollar I told you
it's been inflating you know people were
like questioning in and stuff like that
so Bitcoin protection could become you
know that the standard where all
currencies are pegged against or if it's
not so that's a potential I'm not gonna
say will happen but it certainly it
holds that promise yeah question of that
um good question though like the private
key on if yours if you're selling or
exchanging a fraction of your Bitcoin
and does it create a new private key for
them yeah roses remember bitcoins only
held in Bitcoin accounts so if you take
you need a private key to move the
Bitcoin out of the account and every
time you move you have to move the whole
thing out so it's kind like this it's
kind of like you have you have a you
have a
cake in your refrigerator if I want to
eat the cake I gotta open the fridge
with your private key and then what I
have to do is that take the whole cake
out first and then I cut it you never
cut the cake in the fridge right you
take the cake out and then you cut it if
you have one cake or half of can you
take it out and you cut however much you
want and then what you can do is because
the fridge is where your account and
your your private keys the opening of it
in the fridge then you have two pieces
you have the piece you want to eat and
the piece that's left over what you do
then is you could take the piece you
want to eat you give it to whoever you
want to give it to the pieces left over
you can either put it back in the same
fridge or you can put a new put in the
new fridge so most people put it into a
new account so that was a long it was
accurate what do you think about the
other digital currencies and do you
think you're gonna support them in the
future I love all the other currencies
but I can't comment on what we'll do in
the future yes thank you yes so it's
like online access to your exchange
online access website your website like
machine yes we have API access as well
that's right that's right among coughs
hello i'm bt charity goodbye from bits m
seller on mon cause you could do all
that
yeah arbitrage yeah but you're not the
first to think of it so what is Bitcoin
caring for governments not for
individuals because government's
sovereign governments always view this
is a sovereign right right as you know
is used for control that's right control
your imports and extracts no absolutely
why should a government see better
control because because it's coming it's
coming
I'll tell you it's like the internet it
used to be that I when I grew up in
Africa I'll tell you a story I read
because the country it was relatively
stable but you know what was the most
important thing in the country you know
where they actually had armed guards it
was at the television station that was a
place in the whole city where that armed
guards the television station had a
tower so controlling
the communication the broadcasts of the
TV station of the radio was so critical
from maintaining order and government
you know so that was I reek lows in the
US we have free press and all that stuff
but pre-internet car communication was
very important to countries right
but now the internet is here even in
China today with the Great Firewall of
China
the reality is information is becoming
more free people you and me ordinary
citizens can now broadcast and tell our
stories right it's a Twitter it's the
you know it's the WeChat or whether it's
called a whatsapp or you know things
like that
does that make sense so it's coming it's
it's I don't want to use a phrase and
stoppable I didn't say that and stop but
but you get the idea
yeah okay okay so to earlier point if I
guess find money from BBC China and then
I saw I sell my Bitcoin I'm a monk asana
means I can transfer the money let me be
from China outside of China without an
invitation
because right now we'll have an
invitation all transport my name because
right now yes I do I took a plane flew
times just so I could have carried a lot
of money with me today how much I was
like six hundred US dollars okay you go
so the point is there's laws and it is
breaking laws right so laws are there
and you can always break them but you
have to face the consequence right am i
right the situation I admission right
now is there consideration of violation
of Chinese law I'm not a lawyer but I I
would urge you to look at the law more
carefully before
model like money to transfer or money
reminisce but across countries I should
not say that go for I should have said
go study it first no yeah that's great
so we are not in the business of making
evading capital easier I want to make
that very clear we're gonna have
anti-money laundering rules in place we
don't have kyc in place and that's part
of the regulation in terms of regulating
Bitcoin exchanges that's true in China
it's going to be true in the U it's
already true in the u.s. it's going to
be true in Thailand and in every country
I mean basically countries and
governments will have have the right to
administer and set their own laws and
I'm fully supportive that unless you
want to go to a country where there's no
laws right so so as a business in the
country we fall in the domain of the
government of the law legal system so we
have to follow those rules and
regulations okay sir here it will happen
my prediction it will happen by itself
organically we'll just let it flow we
just let the market play off it's like
the internet 20 years ago who was on the
internet it was just random people you
know putting up pictures of themselves
and stuff like that
and how do you go from that society to
today where you have eBay and Amazon and
in real commerce going on even with
internet banking so it will happen it'll
happen right it's it's not the force of
one company or one person pushing it
it's the force of the whole society
changing in that direction
because they all want it to happen right
okay about that this is this is fun part
okay here we go here we go
so how many of you have more than one
Bitcoin raise your hand okay how many of
you have less than one Bitcoin oh wow
interesting so uh so there are a lot of
you who have Bitcoin the less than one
so okay this is this is op now I want to
talk about a little bit uh off the
record
sort of conversation okay here's why so
I'm the CEO of this of this exchange so
I should it's it's my duty to have a
neutral perspective I should not be
encouraging speculation am i right
you don't want you don't want like the
you know head of the New York Stock
Exchange to say buy buy buy stocks you
know that'd be wrong right so so I I I'm
fully aware of that but but at the same
time I got into this spot because I
believe in the future of Bitcoin and by
that definition I believe in the future
price a future higher price of Bitcoin
that's why I am where I am today okay
that's that's that's no there's no lie
that's the truth so I'll tell you about
my private thoughts about where the
Bitcoin prices could go but it is not a
sign as to encourage you to buy Bitcoin
okay so for example one Bitcoin today is
a thousand dollars and there's how many
totally now there could be at most 21
million in the next hundred years so
that's a lot but the reality is not a
lot there's 7 billion people Shanghai
has a population of 20 million if
everyone is Shanghai bought a Bitcoin
you know it'd be it'd be over there's no
more left right so uh so so my point is
this gold okay how much gold is there
here 120 of them announced right it's
about worth about 60 US dollars you guys
remembered it turns out if I have one
Bitcoin that means I have 120 one
millionth of the world's supply of
bitcoins am i right is that a large
number it's a large number I mean is
that a lot of bitcoins it's only one but
as a fractional it's actually quite
significant I mean not for this room but
the whole world seven billion people so
if I told you I I'll give you one over
twenty one millionth of all the gold in
the world you know how much that is take
a guess how many of these would there be
unison my question am I in the world you
slice it into 21 million pieces and I
give you one slice how much gold would
there be more or less than this a lot
more a lot about five to ten kilograms
if I think that's about $400,000 in
today's prices okay so if Bitcoin were
to ever have an asset value equivalent
of gold
if okay here's the big part right then
one Bitcoin could potentially be around
four hundred thousand US dollars right
and that's only matching Gold's asset
class so my prediction is Bitcoin one
day has a potential to become a truly
global asset class remember if there's
no leg it's not English bitcoin is not
an American thing it's not in English
it's not a Chinese it's not a Western
culture Eastern culture thing it's a
global thing it runs on the whole
internet right can I become a global in
a global asset class can it become a
global currency standard in 100 years in
20 years right I think it has a
potential that's why we're passionate
doing this company during the startup
we're gonna have to call them yeah so
what one last sentence is if it does
become that it will become a
trillion-dollar asset class which is
more than 100 times awareness today
you